[Music]
you married outside of your family's
faith is that correct yeah so we're you
know we're Muslim and she's she's not
Muslim and so well my family was very
understanding very welcoming so we had
this like Muslim ceremony at my parents
house we were small and your wife was
okay with that that it be there yeah
that she marries sort of in a Muslim
ceremony she was cool with it yeah she
was cool with it we did both you know we
did like Muslim one and then we did the
wrong one and what is happening today
yeah good so I so we're all there and
we're gonna get her families that my
family's there and the Muslim priest guy
comes in and he's like what's the name
of the guy and they go Kemal and he's
like that's a beautiful name and they go
and he goes what's the name of the woman
and they go Emily and he goes I'm not
gonna marry someone named Emily really
yeah very intense and that was she
dressed by the way he's walk or is he in
this is what he looked like
pretend you're a racist and then imagine
a Muslim
[Laughter]
yeah he look he looked like a Muslim on
the news you know he checked all the
boxes yeah so my mom freaks out and she
comes to Emily she's like hey can we
change your name just for today and
Emily's very nice so she's like sure we
change her name to Iman just for the day
and so in Muslim ceremonies the men and
the women sit separately so it's me I'm
sitting next to this guy and then up the
stairs is Emily within like earshot and
I hate this guy you know I hate this
this is your time idea yeah then the
person complains service yeah yeah I
hate it because he's like so
close-minded and while and I'm just
sitting there like oh I wish was someone
else marrying me not someone else
marrying me
well she had a different cleric yes yes
halfway through the ceremony in the room
Beyonce's naughty girl starts playing
but just the chorus like I'm a naughty
girl I'm a naughty girl I'm a naughty
girl and I'm looking around like oh my
god who has this as their ringtone I
swear I swear this Muslim cleric reaches
into his pocket pulls out a glowing cell
phone flips it open to see who's calling
cuz that's just as general ringtone for
everyone
that's not like Oh naughty girls the
bedroom must be calling you know and he
but he doesn't turn it off and he puts
it down and for another 20 seconds
beyond sin the Quran harmonized together
and this guy it's amazing this guy won't
perform a service for Emily but yeah
that's his that's what he's listening to
you know I mean Beyonce transcends all
faiths
[Laughter]
you